today we're combining pool with ping
pong with the amazing Venom trick shots
let's see which sport wins let's compare
the spins sounds good
[Music]
not bad not bad
there
we have it
oh that's good just enough
oh that's good easy well not easy fun
[Music]
nice this is my version of the Around
the Net shot
[Music]
[Applause]
that's burnt yeah it just burns that was
cool all right eight ball corner pocket
[Music]
there we go
help us get to 5 million and hit
subscribe oh that looks terrified
that looks so sketchy
so you're just gonna have to not move
it's so funny can you blame me that I'm
a bit scared two foot three
let's go
[Music]
and three
let me try something else I'll go back
in position I want to do it without
looking no look first shots
[Music]
this is what we call the four in one
you're gonna make all the balls in one
shot okay sounds good
[Music]
okay okay next one is in just a little
bit softer there's a lot of potential
here so whatever you're doing
okay
we're gonna make your pool players again
that was cool that was cool you're
looking to hit like a a quarter of the
eight ball on the right side yeah it's
more like this
foreign
[Music]
yes
not bad let's pretend that I knew what I
was doing jump shot over to Black Bulls
cue ball flies into the red split them
one on the left one on the right
let's see if he's got that
nice elevation less worse
it's closed
oh perfect nice finally the Sensei is
here and still I didn't do anything only
what Florian told me to do yeah the fun
part is that I'm mature is not learning
anything
thank you
[Music]
yeah
oh yeah
[Music]
I see the base
time to switch the balls
[Music]
wow look at that she invite those guys
from Finland and then what happens they
destroy your house
oh we got that nice it actually works
time for jumping around tonight
[Music]
oh nice one
we got four
oh
[Music]
that was a good rally I can't say it was
easy though
thanks
[Music]
oh that is real truck
if it works
[Music]
I know it's a trust you but I don't
trust you
how good is that though I was very
impressed
oh my God good one wow there's no joke
the first try the group professional
YouTube time to get my revenge
[Music]
even trying to get in the conversation
Payback right now
oh okay it actually hurts sorry about
that oh yeah you look very sorry
oh it did fall up it's a little delayed
but I think it worked all right so
Florence it's your time to learn some
spins and table sets go around and into
the cup the key is getting below the
ball if Florian makes this shot you guys
have to hit subscribe this sounds like a
plan
start though good start
oh you can have it quite open yeah
that's that's good that's the one just
think think like that
yeah nice yes that's the one
that is insane
it's cool it really is cool it's the
same concept really that deserves to
subscribe to Venom trick shots go check
his channel he does crazy stuff
backspin around the line
[Music]
for me